the latest shake-up within the Trump
administration leaves national security
advisor John Bolton out of a job
Bolton says he handed in his resignation
yesterday the president says he asked
Bolton to leave because they did not
agree on key issues sources tell our
major Garrett the breaking point was the
president's belief that Bolton are those
close to him leaked a story claiming
that mr. Trump suggested using nuclear
weapons to stop a hurricane Bolton was
president Trump's third national
security adviser General Michael Flynn
lasted just 24 days from January to
February of 2017 Flynn was fired after
lying to vice president Mike Pence about
contacts with Russia's ambassador to the
u.s. next was general HR McMaster he was
appointed in February of 2017 and
stepped down in April of 2018 Bolton had
the job the longest serving from April
of last year until yesterday CBS News
senior national security analyst Fran
Townsend is with us she was homeland
security adviser during the George W
Bush administration and worked with
Bolton good morning Fran having worked
with mr. Bolton in the bush White House
what do you think happened here exactly
you know look III do think John resigned
I we've now wanted Axios reported this
morning an actual tick-tock of the
timeline and so I but I don't really
think it matters right what does matter
is there's no since the position was
established no president has run through
three and now going on his fourth
national security adviser in three years
and so if you're thinking about taking
that job you might take note of that
what does that suggest about policy at
the White House
I don't think look the policy that's
driven at the White House is a function
of the president not of the national
security adviser and so the more
important issue to me is there's no
discipline policy process if you're
going into that job you want to know
that you're gonna run a policy process
that brings in different point of views
differences of opinion are not a bad
thing in the White House but the message
here is if you disagree with the
president you're out yeah I mean it
seems to be it does seem to be and I
will tell you look John is a very
principled guy president Trunk knew what
he was getting when he
hire John Bolton and I think John Bolton
understood from the beginning is that if
they had policy differences he was going
to go could so much turnover in this key
position affect our security as
Americans I don't think so look if the
good news here is that the agencies are
gonna go about their work you've got a
very strong Secretary of State and Mike
Pompeo who's got enjoys a very good
relationship with the president and I
think we ought to expect that the State
Department and the Department of Defense
are gonna continue to go about their
business what do you make of the fact
though friend that they're both trying
to say no I fired you know I resigned no
I fired you know I resign what does that
say to you what does that mean
you know Gayle it's sort of more of the
same right there's a bit of
finger-pointing
it's unfortunate because I think you
know the president in his tweet did
thank John for his service and if that's
all he had done he would have treated
him with dignity and respect and I don't
think we would have seen it john bolton
replied tweet right i I think this is a
distraction this is sort of typical of a
White House that can't just can't let it
go let it go and move on Boulton and
secretary Pompeo reportedly clashed
frequently in the Trump White House and
I think Secretary Pompeo confirmed that
yesterday look it's okay though Anthony
that they can have disagreements as long
as the sort of goals are the same and I
think they did share the same goal for
example on Iran there was actually a
good deal of agreement oftentimes
there's disagreements in the policy
process on tactics and again as I'd say
to you that's a good thing for the
president because he ought to get a
fulsome view and understand what the
disagreements the pros and cons are but
as Gael points out it doesn't seem like
that's what this president wants when
he's in time today the president gets to
choose who he wants on his team that's
also true
that's exactly right and he gets to
choose the process by which it gets run
how his white house gets run and so
that's really up to the president all
right Fran thank you we shall see who
the president picks we'll have you back
to talk about that are you interested
yeah